if I could go back and you could only
give me one skill to begin with and I
had to build from all of it I can tell
you for sure what it would be for me so
proving your family wrong or right is
the symptom of the same disease which is
you are still obsessed with what other
people are thinking about you most
people's will to win is for sale once or
get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best ed my let and the five skills that
can make or break your success mentor me
IDI
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one persuade people one of the questions
I get asked the most often is about what
skill do I think is the most important
as an entrepreneur that's a really
difficult question but if I could go
back and you could only give me one
skill to begin with and I had to build
from all of it I can tell you for sure
what it would be for me and that would
be the ability to influence so it's the
ability to persuade people without that
skill set the vast majority of my wealth
does not exist if you can't persuade
people
if you can't influence people to make
decisions that are in their own best
interest but that also grow your
business your brand your company your
net worth
you can't ever become successful one
thing that everybody I know that's a
leader and everything they do can do is
persuade people no I watch people do
that in all different types of ways some
do it through intimidation some through
do it through force some do it through
humor so I'm do it through persuasive
strategies transfer of energy you name
it but all leaders can persuade all
successful people can get people to make
decisions on their own best interests
that also get them to participate with
their company it's the number one skill
that I see most people not spending the
most time on is their ability to
communicate their ability to persuade
people and because they're constantly
trying to go to a different course or
they think that somehow if their product
is good enough or they get the right
sales pitch that somehow they're gonna
win but the fact of the matter is you've
got to become a better person
rule number two stop worrying what
others think trying to prove people
wrong or write about you is a cheap
level of motivation and it will wear out
in other words it's not and it's not the
lack of it it's just it's not the best
type people say well hey Tom Brady a six
round draft pick I mean he's constantly
trying to prove them that they picked
the wrong guys I know Tommy a little bit
and I can tell you that motivates him
but if you think he's become the
greatest football player of all time
because he's trying to prove people from
20 years ago wrong about where he was
drafted you don't get elite performance
Tom Brady is where he is because he sets
standards for himself and has massive
goals and ambitions for him
self not to prove other people wrong I
promise you when he's sitting on her
Center in the Super Bowl he's not going
I was a six round draft pick that's not
what moves him yeah and so I think it's
a low level motivation I do it too and
the sooner you drop it's it's a it's the
symptom of the same disease right so
proving your family wrong or right is
the symptom of the same disease which is
you are still obsessed with what other
people are thinking about you and not
doing things that make you happy that
enrich you to fulfill your soul and so
the irony about spending your life
worrying about what everybody else
thinks about you here's the irony is
that those people will never be thought
about after they're dead so they spend
their life obsessing with everyone
thinks about them only to die and have
no one ever remember them because people
that are so obsessed with what other
people think about them never really
ever fulfill their potential so once you
can drop that addiction whether it's
friends strangers or your parents and
you begin to do things that fulfill you
that make you happy yeah that change
other people's lives by your
contribution now you can be remembered
now you're your life that goes into
eternity even if it was a quiet life
also if you want to learn what
entrepreneurs like Edie have to say
about building confidence check out my
to 54 series it's free and the link is
in the description below so while you're
in this passionate state that's where
you make decisions you have to go build
self-confidence the reason people don't
put themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
rule number three have a strong why left
to my own devices right if you just left
me like what I'd like to do
I hate man I have no problem laying
around I like sleep I got people think
they meet people like you know they're
like they're robots they're other
life-forms they're just different than
me know we build habits rituals and
disciplines that serve us okay now part
of those habits rituals and disciplines
have sort of turned me into a more
confident person there's no question
about that
so my standards are mandatory because
you get your standards right and so the
reason my standards are set whole so
high is because I don't want to leave it
up to my own devices right my standard
is one more minute on the treadmill my
standard is one more person I can reach
that day one more phone call one more
something and so for me I raise them
every single year but the way I
get to do it as I linked it to my
reasons and so goals are really empty to
me I have a thing on goal-setting but
like my big thing is that you show me
something with compelling emotional
gigantic reasons I'll show you someone
who's changing their standards all day
long so like give you one quick version
that you not heard before one of the
reasons I'm relatively fit is not just
peak state I have an uncle in my family
that died at 50 years old of a heart
attacks my godfather my dad's only
brother I kind of resembled him and I
look like him a lot so on the way back
from his funeral my reticular activating
on heart attacks on the TV screen on the
airplane I'm listening to music is the
Oprah Winfrey Show she's going through a
new heart scan hmm I've unplugged my
headphones plugging into the airplane
one there's some of this new scan at
cedars-sinai that at that time was new
it could read the plaques in your
arteries the calcifications without
doing you know really invasively
I scheduled it I went in I had a
world-class doctor who understood
reasons and levers instead of just
prescribing clues but when we coach
people you need to do this you need to
do this that doctors do it take just
pill take this he understood leverage
and reasons what you do is you take the
scan then you go to lunch you come back
I took the scan I went to which I had a
burrito I came back and I'm in the LA
when I walk in I sit down the doctor
comes up and he says oh my I can't
believe these arteries are in that young
body got my attention we walk back in we
sit down he could still go you need
Crestor eat clean get out of here is
know what an average doctor does right
no wired me with huge reasons he goes
let me ask you a question I heard your
wife's pregnant you have I said I have a
son and he says do you want to be there
when he graduates from high school to be
there for that day I said yes sir yeah
he goes your wife's pregnant what do you
have it I said a daughter this is where
you get a dad he goes she was six months
pregnant he goes do you um would you
like to walk her down the aisle on her
wedding day or are you okay that it's
some other man I went what the is on
this scan right like and he goes I want
to be very clear with you if you keep
going down the road you're going
there'll be some other man with your son
at graduation high school and a
strangers walking your daughter down the
aisle that's not even born yet on her
wedding day and I went to him and he
goes but if you do exactly what I tell
you to do you'll be there and so to this
day brother there are mornings when I
wake up not every morning
don't want to go to the gym I go Bella's
wedding Bella's wedding Bella's wedding
so my standards are high because of my
big old reasons other dudes may miss the
gym that day cuz they're not gonna miss
their daughter's wedding if they don't
go but I've convinced myself I will get
emotional I've convinced myself on this
my daughter's wedding so I will get my
ass out of bed at 4 o'clock in the
morning and I will get to that gym
because my reasons are bigger so my
standards are higher so that's what I
think causes us to have great standards
as huge reasons rule number four persist
you've been very successful as an
entrepreneur have you always been
successful you just said the word
entrepreneur and always successful so
yeah everything I have ever done work
you over there lying it right oh well
they're not an entrepreneur they've
inherited something right because if you
if you're an entrepreneur you have not
always been successful right so from
Steve Jobs down all the way and so I've
had successes and then I'll go backwards
so what like most entrepreneurs there's
false start after false start after
false starts so I would get it going and
it would go backwards I saved some money
then I'd blow it you know my business
would grow then it would shrink and then
so no I've had I've had tons of
different financial events happen in my
life and actually actually after people
thought I was pretty successful I'd
become a millionaire about 26 years old
I'd become a millionaire I was making a
million dollars a year and I ended up
losing it all and it ended up I lost a
home I lost a car I ended up moving into
an apartment I was newly married I'll
never forget this I remember cuz this
oceans out there we're looking at it
right now and yeah I remember honestly
defining moment you I had everything
turned off you got a power turned off
and still survive one thing I learned
you don't want your water turned off and
we had the water cut off so I'm lives
easier newlywed my new and six weeks
married we end up still with you
she's still with me she won't run here
somewhere yeah she's with me that's the
one thing common I know we do well high
school and the same thing with her with
her with their wives and long story
short we had to go every morning out of
the apartment go down to the pool and
shower outdoors and you bring her
toothbrush it was just shameful for me
and rule number five the last one before
a very special bonus clip is don't sell
your will to win all those people's will
to win is for sale is for sale most
people's will will is for sale win is
for sale they can be Bob
t-bob so if we give you just most people
if we gave me just enough money if
there's a certain dollar amount it's not
working I know you stop working hard we
give you a car or a plane or a house or
that's the book bro
that's the book yeah that might be the
book that is the book so what your will
to win is for sale that's right and I
decided once I realize that because I
watch it happen with people in their
body and their finances and their family
and their faith whatever it is I want
not enough for sale so there isn't a
place you're gonna buy me you can't get
me there's not a stop a place of
destination where you're gonna get me to
relent to quit I want to improve that
doesn't mean I don't struggle with my
motivation from time to time doesn't
mean I don't get confused or down of
course I do I'm not for sale yeah you
can't buy me and you know this too we
see a friends of ours even guys in their
60s or they sold their company for blah
blah blah now they golf nine days a week
or whatever you know that's fun but yet
for sale
they burbot you or buy you were for sale
I'm not for sale now I've got a special
bonus tip from end on how to get in
touch with your gifts that I really
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three point landing
questions let's move from just watching
a video to taking action in your life
for business here we go question number
one what is your strong why number two
whose opinion do you need to stop
worrying about and number three how will
you work today on your persuasion skills
when I was small mom I was also really
under sized
so it's probably the reason I lift
weights I was always there every
baseball picture I'm the kid holding the
sign in the front right so I was small
and skinny these two teased me Eddie
spaghetti you know and I'd get bullied
at school and I never retaliated so I
had that mix with shyness mixed with
chaos in my home which many people can
relate to and I got to tell you the the
shift for me sports was good for me
because it gave me an Al that I finally
found something that I was pretty good
at I think the biggest shift in our
lives the things that makes us the
happiest is that when somebody helps us
identify our natural giftedness and when
I was a little boy when I got a little
bit older they pointed out my speed so
wasn't my lack of size I was fast
I was the fast kid right I always wanted
to be fast kid and I got confidence in
baseball doing that when I got into
business they said you know you're
intense but someone points out a gift
about you that you also kind of into
we know to be true they're linked to him
if you're intense you're passionate you
won't get out work you're relentless I
want I am those things and when someone
linked those gifts to me winning now I
believed I could win that's the other
way to change identity it's when someone
can link your giftedness to the victory
you'll believe it not like you're great
that's general that's [ __ ] but it's
something you know specific like for you
right now
you wouldn't brag them there's a few
things you know you know what I am good
at these things right I've always been
good at these things that's natural for
me and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example you're
an unbelievable interviewer you have
this general you don't need to be the
smartest person in the room because you
probably are most of the time and so
there's a confidence know there's a
confidence that allows you to be present
when you interview me and just listen
that's different than anyone who's
interviewed me before and so that's a
natural giftedness for you which is why
there's a part of you that kind of knows
I am pretty you wouldn't say if I am
pretty good at this
this is a good program and so the way we
change our identity the way I changed
mine was by getting in touch with with
some of my natural gifts were and then
using them in my career using them in my
life that shifted the weight right off
of me because the weight was I suck I'm
shy I'm small I have a screwed up family
that's the weight right the lifting off
of the way it is these are some gifts
God gave me or the universe gave me or
that at least I know I have and I can
spend my life using these gifts now I've
got hope now my identity is changing now
my life takes a different direction
if you want more add my let check at the
top ten rules video I made on him right
there I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there we all
know someone right now in our life or we
have who's not ethical who's not a good
person who's winning and they're like I
can't believe they're getting it right
why can't I I'm a good person